you
hello everyone welcome back to GameSpot
I am Mike I am honored to be here with
Patrice daesil a and you at the recent
game awards finally you got to show off
ancestors finally yes I got to show up
and I'm really happy that this morning I
will also finally be playing it well
thanks so much for joining us
yeah we might as well jump right in is
there anything you want to talk about
the game before we you get to show us
some of the gameplay Oh single-player
third-person open world action survival
game this is what we're working on
making in Montreal and I just press
Start and so we can we can start and and
what I want to talk about first is this
is an actual build
yeah it's not something special it's not
the demo it's not already yesterday yes
and it's like yeah really hot from the
oven so so we'll start a new lineage
okay okay this is the lineage is what
you're actually going to play throughout
your experience with ancestors and so
I'll pick a new slot it's simple for now
and we'll start the first time because
it was the first time you see it and yet
that people are actually also seen it
and we won't play with any tutorial if
you don't mind okay and we'll play a pro
mode so dad know you're the expert on
little pop ups nothing ok alright
and so people can also enjoy just being
in Africa ten million years ago
absolutely and and and let's let's do it
and you want to play as a male or a
female
or we go random random random yeah good
ready yep here we go
and then it's that's a loading screen
it's called and now we're into us we're
playing a game right from the beginning
the very very beginning okay and so
since it's an actual build what I want
to say it'll be like it was like a lot
of places for improvement for us isn't
the game is not
finished yet and and that's how we work
we do a lot of bills per day 10 from 10
to 20 bills a day and I'll just have to
be playable ok wise I go crazy and now
I'll just let you experience it cool
you
you
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was quite the setup now it
starts so this is ten million years ago
I'm playing to live the little baby that
just is all alone in the jungle
and now he's really afraid he's in the
fear zone fear mode need to find a place
to actually hide the baby and then maybe
a novelty will come and save him
so obviously this is much longer ago
than any other game you've made
obviously oh yeah it's not that what was
the Third Crusade in 71
yeah it's not just Ritu's Renaissance is
the same thing Prince of Persia I was
like fictional but but housing in one
night yeah so this is much longer yeah
so this you said this is like a fear
this is like an actual state that you
know I'm you one of the adult killed
which for you may happen often
mm-hm you'll you know if you're all
alone in the expedition you'll be you
know your baby will be spare if you will
and you need to find a place to actually
hide your baby you're now going to my
intelligence mode and trying to find a
place to hide the baby that's a height
spot okay can mark it
alright so nah see I can see it
even in the 3d world okay so you marked
it just like without even going into a
map or anything or just straight through
the UI exactly there's no any map or map
whatever you have to map it up in your
in your head okay
getting there and I can actually hide my
baby so what I understand this ape soon
to be hominid soon in the grand sense
will eventually control continue the
species by surviving and maybe exactly
becomes you and me sitting here right
now yes that's the I ten million since
this is a bit the story of how we got to
now okay and it took a lot of time sure
yeah and like we'll get into this I'm
sure so I'm probably jumping the gun but
it is a much more systemic oh thank you
especially like you are known for like
yeah yeah I'm known for historical
action adventure with a really strong
narrative when you're telling a story
this like you're setting up us like with
the systems for us exactly so now I'm
going to my sans trying to locate where
the night baby is but this time around
yeah it's all about you writing your own
adventure it left me yeah my writing one
for you so again I mark where my baby is
hiding in it okay
so there's kind of like that SAS
discrete flavor but on a more natural
environment exactly more my Danny well I
got at first when we're starting panache
and the team so okay how do I make an
historical game with 30 people because
everything you're seeing right now it's
done by 30 people back in Montreal it
was like so if we go prehistoric it will
be easier because I will not have to
build an entire civilization and no
crowd and no architecture and it was a
bit naive of me because then it's all
organic
yeah it's not easier it's difficult yeah
it's different yeah okay about something
else so it's all like organic angles and
branches and exactly and and and how do
you actually read organic stuff right so
how we did it is is that each time you
have like
trunk like that you can climb them and
you don't have to do anything right okay
and if you press the a button which is
the physical aspect it goes faster and
if you release he jumps okay okay can
you sign on most surfaces on all
surfaces yeah it's a bit my thing right
okay now so picked up my baby and I'll
go back in between my what we call a
settlement aways this and I'm back and
where have you been so that was another
adult
yeah that's your clan I got a gram here
waiting for me and you went to save the
baby from the hiding spot that you
yourself had initially known exactly
okay and since it's a you know survival
game you have to eat drink and sleep
again in order for you to survive I
picked up something that I never picked
up before so that's why there's a bit of
the dark on it so I don't know what it
is or just like inspect it so the last
stuff is like visual cues within the
world rather than like a UI a HUD but
yeah you know it's not my thing in
general yeah is on game so it's probably
one of the first if not the first
survival game without any menus okay
that's interesting yeah I think so too
yeah and so I'll just like I'd eat and
I'll come in my my plan to eat them so
okay so you're also like a leader of
sorts
yeah exactly but you're not really the
leader because I can switch between
character but I'll keep that for another
demo if you will say see so each time
you pick something new you have to
inspect it first and remove the fear out
of the character eating will also give
you dopamine that will help you out and
I'll show you how later on in the game
don't picked up the branch for the first
time don't need it now so I'll just
leave it there that's interesting
because panache digital you and several
people incorporated in 2014 yeah in that
time it seems like many like maybe not
many but several Triple A games and
Studios have gone toward that survival
kind of more systemic like even is Elda
did it like even the recent Red Dead to
kind of had more survival elements that
wasn't that system driven but it's just
it's interesting I wonder what it's like
to be making this game while you see
other Steel's conduit their own takes on
you know we're trying a lot of different
things all in our little space and it's
it's it's interesting to see other
people trying the same thing because
then you say okay we're not totally
crazy sure right and so but at the same
time the way a design it's like what's
my subject matter okay we're like it's
about survival right and and also it
started all by feeling that right now
we're mutants we're so different than
what our ancestors were like or some
offshoot that just and we're sort of
like biologically like a build to
survive and be afraid of dangers that is
lurking everywhere and right now as you
see it's it's the blue around the screen
it's because it's raining and I'm I'm
cold
okay and so I'm using more energy okay
and but I just want to see hope you just
want to see this is my the elder we've
got you just kind of see where we use it
where are you so based on the beginning
when your baby it looked like there was
like a decent amount of falling damage
I'm assuming oh man
this is poor dude I don't think he's
gonna wake up whoa the same bird yeah no
I guess you were in his nest yeah her
eggs so get out of there yeah it's
interesting you were saying like so many
like primal fears we still have they're
not logical in our world today but
there's no because there's no more big
birds trying to to to get you but well
speak for yourself
okay I don't know that sliced it what
was your morning like it took a Hoover
and everything was fine yeah
sounds nice so you can see this like
ingredients all over the place and it's
really for you to figure out if they're
good for your character okay and see I
was still eating and that's the the
thing while you talk and trying to
survive a African jungle danger is
everywhere all the time
right just go down a little bit so
obviously pretty much every game you've
made or at least the games you've
directed were very took a lot of
research for that historical period when
you and I were talking before I started
I was thinking I don't I need to brush
up on my anthropology but I know there
was knowing your portfolio there was
probably a lot of research into that
kind of stuff for this game I said it
before in other interviews and it's like
I'm not really original because I pick
you know time period historical time
period I study them and then I recreate
them yeah right so and for this one's
like I wanted to tell the the the
biggest adventure of of it all which is
ours the one that's that started at all
and so yes I had to
study our species if you will right and
how we go like I said how we go to now
is it getting too much into spoilers
just to like so the I saw that this was
like chapter one right yeah yeah no
volume volume one gotcha okay no chapter
no it's like it's a real open world game
it's like right now we feel like that
lasts at least 50 hours to go through it
all okay Wow okay okay it's just that
one when I was with some you know
studying the subject I found it's like
nobody is telling the very beginning of
it all it's like when we're in the trees
and then eventually we learn how to
stand on the two feet right and so that
became volume 1 because that stands like
from 10 to 8 to 2 million years ago okay
with and that that will be volume 1 so
on and eventually you'll get to Lucy the
most well known Australopithecus right
so this is one of the other clans
younger members clinging to your back
yeah sorry you I'm assuming your based
on the fact that's a systemic game is
there some sort of obviously you want to
protect the baby um so it's your
responsibility to yeah baby you need you
need it he's the one who's actually will
help you evolve yeah needs to survive
he's collecting data knowledge for you
and you'll see at the end of my little
play truth and I'm entering another fear
zone because I'm too far away from the
rest of my class and a settlement so now
I'm gonna use their sense that I showed
before to gain knowledge about my
surrounding okay went I'll know enough
I'll be able to eventually unfair
that zone okay to gain more territories
see
now I got enough knowledge and the
little particles it's telling me where
to go to go and unfair
my zone what were those markings that
you had what were those things that you
noticed like animal mark on the trees
this one was like horsetail something I
hate before oh right right and there's
like others that I haven't I think this
one and this I haven't never I'd never
discovered it okay so this one is not
useful for a fear but I could go so it's
it's recognizing things that yeah
removes the fear okay
and that's a oh it doesn't know if it's
good or bad for him okay want me to eat
it or let me just first go through the
fear something about wild mushrooms this
is me and now that territory is mine if
you will okay
and as you can see now it's all cooler
looking exactly colors no but also it's
like the fear is gone right right yeah
so now I can go back here of any time I
walked without the fear interfere with
with my play session like any play so
like you said there's no map you're just
kind of you are mapping out mentally
yeah
what better get out crocodile was never
good
- though just for you - looks like it's
also getting dark nephal day/night cycle
yep just like yeah was didn't do it just
for the menu at the beginning okay
although it was a nice touch forward
menu thank you what I'll do I'll pick up
a tree branch earliest example of tools
yeah yeah you know at first I you picked
it up in my oasis and said I didn't need
it but probably I'll need it here so
I'll be fine for a while but like you
said it's like it's getting dark
yeah so I better get back to my to my
clan and I'll show you the cool stuff
there because right now I'm like
exploring a lot yeah so that's what's
interesting because it's a system driven
game and like you said you literally
spout out the beginning say we're not
gonna help you much no you don't really
miss you don't have an objective
dictating to you right now it's kind of
what you decide but I'll show you where
eventually you can get some addictive
but it's really that that's because
while I was designing it with the team
you know we asked herself to say yeah
but if we say too much how will the
player answered the main question which
is a you of MOS AP ins
can you survive what your ancestors went
through and if we give you you know how
does it work where to go and whatnot
we're answering your question for you
yeah so it's more like yeah you think
you're good but most sapiens like you do
it bringing us down a peg yeah a little
bit maybe but like overarching like in
internal mental objective right now is
just survive it survive and then and
then eventually you get like me it's a
little bit more than surviving right now
right I'm getting off no this is like
see your most salient was talking too
much it's now I got hurt
yep you know what I'll do see I go back
into my sense and this is here more
still and since I know or still is good
it's a good analgesic I guess it's the
right time so we'll get me get better
with my limping okay now I'm good okay
I totally ill myself be and that's it's
because my feels for sure it's because I
designed the game but mostly also is
being here it's because you probably
test it out before share and trying to
understand how things work and so I
haven't showed it but you can get poison
you can get injured by predators right
you can get bleeding and said then it's
a real survival game sure oh I got hurt
by falling if you will and so since it's
the end of the day I'll go my bed oh
yeah this is back in your yes I'm right
and back there and what I'll do I'll
just like for us to sleep in and so so
what are the negative effects of being
out when it's dark
aside from vision being obscured this is
there's no real but there's just a
little bit more predators coming out
okay at night and see this is like
dreams helping you telling you a bit
what you can do and that's my daily
regimen so did I eat enough drink enough
slept enough for my next 24 hours okay
but without the hood it's a bit
difficult for you to share yeah but with
the HUD and there is a life bar right
right right a bar and there's a bunch of
information but the other purposes of
this yes I know what people to know
exactly but I want also people to
experience the 3d world and experience
the real thing afterwards but now since
I'm in the bed and that
I mean my my who is this I can also go
into my our evolution menu and I can
unlock new ability so now I can unlock
for example my sense and I'll be able to
send stuff from further so this is like
the most basic floor earned maybe not
basic it's the most primal form of a
skill tree exactly looking like what we
take for granted
uh-huh that's totally let's go and
hearing well unlock for you know so you
didn't just look into like anthropology
and stuff you looked into like sorry
it's like physiology exactly and what I
long luck here is the very first step of
us okay alright so that now is like your
first step toward walking upright
exactly that's really cool when you
think about it does like a like a skill
tree does fit this really well your
skill tree is evolution within a game
exact is evolution but but I'm so when I
was thinking it's like yeah it will be
easier to do organic and jungle and
whatnot but also said yeah human
progression is a progression it's like
so you'll fit a normal game progression
and then we studied it and then we
realize that even in science this is how
it worked
yeah and so now if I come here I can
suddenly you know go on two legs okay
but not for a long time alright they're
not there yet but can go into my sense
and I put on two legs and I see more
stuff further okay that and that pretty
much concludes our play session okay I
could continue for hours which I this
video that's really interesting so like
the actual skill you unlock it lets you
it lets you see furnace see further
which itself is gonna help you survive
longer and here on your hands okay and
as you can see you can see a lot more
and then I know I'm back in 2d I don't
ceil sure so you wanted and just forward
to finishing things off a little bit I'm
just gonna go on top of this tree okay
tallest one so you can have a sense of
the this kale so I really like how
despite the fact that from what you've
been telling me it is a large open world
but because of our limited abilities as
this early ape we can't really have a
sense of it because a we're focused on
our media surrounding that so be we just
literally don't have the vantage points
yet little birds in the morning I feel
oh it's fitting in whoa inside like from
the video you showed the game wars we
saw there are different it's Africa
they're different biomes it's not just
jungle there's planes or swamps and
savanna and lakes that I need to stop
huh otherwise like I said I can play I
played that bill like last night last
night but the night before for two hours
I got totally not lost because I'm where
I am but lost in the in the pure fun
right but I don't want to say too much
for now
even though I think I said a lot possum
well you've piqued my interest but um so
before we end so this is very much like
the first game you've been showing in
how many years 8 now 8 years yes so this
is a big deal for you it is it is it is
because I do I do care about making
games for me it's not just citing a job
something else and and I wanted to tell
that story yeah you know like I said
like nobody is actually telling where
we're really coming from and nobody's
done it in a gear and I and it's so yes
for me it's been yeah eight years man
eight years of yeah a game so no
concrete release date but you are saying
2019 yes 2019 PC ps4 and Xbox one cool
well
thank you so much Patrice desolation for
joining us and also great job the Game
Awards it's nice to see you on stage and
for you to show off the game but I
appreciate you stopping by so much and
that was ancestors humankind Odyssey the
next game the first game from panache
digital the next game from Patrice
désolé of assassin 3-1 - Brotherhood and
sands of time Prince of Persia sands of
time fame but everybody thank you so
much for stopping by and we will see you
around
you